che c'è un uomo da fare in un po volgare
vi spiego sono vestito così perché
stiamo parlando alla casa e che oggi è
il giorno del mio compleanno quindi
auguri a me auguri al mio maledetto
smoking che non ho mai messo in tutta la
mia vita è la prima volta di vasto così
troppo 22 anni legato a caracas non mi
vesto così una volta nella vita almeno
in occasioni importanti guardali che se
la ride mai letto per riti grazie dove
andava vigili devo fare i complimenti
lei di un'eleganza sublimi complimenti
grazie grazie grazie grazie questo mi
dice anche la mamma menez quando andò il
festival dei giovani di gaza
noi siamo persone importanti dove prendi
per colazione io prendo del buon genes
and go
mentre
c'ero anch'io
come d'affari dormono
questo motivo
commendatore
stiamo atterrando è possibile che
così
affari
si lavora più che rabbia
le discipline e se viene strategici per
oggi essendo la stiamo dando a fare
me lo racconti
che le gare sono grazie
si va dai ragazzi di gaeta 1a 2a div
intesa sanpaolo
ed è per questo che gesto così bene e
altro
a fare un po di fondo che i ragazzi poi
ove la morgan live perché io non faccio
lotto forte
[Musica]
cos'è veri uomini d'affari già arrivati
di fuori dal taschino vedere
[Musica]
ecco
macché fatto è sì
è una cosa normalissima per un uomo
d'affari in eleganza in un certo
importanza come la barca è una delle mie
tante vecchie perché noi uomini abbiamo
dalle 3x mai vista carta di credito con
la foto
per prima cosa secondo
la carta significa analizzare
[Musica]
mi son dovuto vestire così in cinque
minuti non mi sono mai visto così tutta
la mia vita in fondo vestire così la
prima volta in due minuti quindi è stato
veramente un casino però sono riuscito
quasi completamente essere elegante
[Musica]
non è vero da mamma mia moti frego anche
la macchina perché questo questo abito
mi conferisce prime può andare dai sei
l'autista di te stesso ciao sbavati come
in gran turismo commendatore a io sono
come un valore lei oggi 26 bloggando to
1 10
hai ragione sei pronto a una cosa per te
come stai fibromi tuo compleanno
sicuramente ti avranno mandato ieri
regali e pacchetti e mi aggiungo anche
io ti mando questo pensiero spero che ti
piaccia
ti auguro buon compleanno frate spacca
tutto ma fibra e questa parte sua non ci
fosse ma noto aveva fatto pure bene
ora la dieta sia proprio la firma grazie
fabrizi fantastico non aspettavo mai
buon compleanno addio davvero luglio
presso un sacco allora ragazzi siamo a
matera bello questo aspetto che abbia il
festival sono qui in veste di
rappresentante della cappa place per
intesa e quindi mi devo vestire a
puntino perché adesso mi sono studiato
durante il viaggio tutte le carte mi
spiega non altri ma come funziona
contrasto cresciuta e devo spiegarla in
un'intervista e quindi ho bisogno di
essere vestito perfetto ma una cravatta
zio frosio per le dita effetti speciali
cleese il proprio ok perfetto ed ora che
si mette nello antonello che già minori
scrive musiche e altri effetti speciali
signore in sempre pronti a fare
l'intervista
salve piacere si ok allora il fatto dal
nome cognome data di nascita codice
fiscale
non è vero forse no perché ci sono messi
capiscano non ricava addirittura ma si
può dire una cosa che tu sei i killer
più famoso d'italia per una domanda come
ti è venuto in mente di fare le cose
come si sa ha iniziato nel 2011 perché
facevo video condivisi gli amici per
però qui poi il pian piano non è stato
la brina nostro canale a far crescere la
nostra e poi abbiamo
quelli che ho deciso di staccarmi di
aprire il mio canale la cosa nasce cosa
e perché sia privati la cravatta ma tra
l'aria non ti ho mai nessuno neanche io
king ha fatto il nuovo io ovviamente non
ci credo stato io
così si è capaci a fare i nodi ma che
dovrà difendere massimo esperto di noi
alle grandi dive secondo te impotenti a
il più da ogni giorno all
beh dipende da anche la tipologia di
vino ad esempio un blog tiene in quanto
viaggiano e quindi loghi nei viaggi
richiedono tanto editing invece è di
vista nel montaggio mentre i videogiochi
e chiedono un po meno tempo perché meno
quelle quattro ore e mano però un errore
si bene la tipo di viso e ciò che sei
quadri che avete in qualità di una festa
dei giovani di qualità in via invitato
super invitato i resti di banca intesa e
quindi la paghiamo francesca che un
signore qualche angelo bianco ok io ti
perdono sei pronto super problema 10 6
ma per me tanto fili per intesa sanpaolo
sei qua io questi siediti si dirà sì
mettete la seduta
ho visto dai tuoi i blogger el america
della tua secondo multisala tua seconda
casa di micro essere comoda la carta
flash all'estero possono acquistare
online per la propria flash e poi nei
negozi che utilizzano circuito che sono
aderenti al circuito della carta molto è
la crisi ma se la prima di poter essere
anche alle interrogazioni professione
tassata andiamo sempre due lo stesso
anche colei che saprete giusto anzi di
mantenere l'ottimo suggerivano a fare
stiamo appunto che se hai un occhio che
ha ideato temi caldi non vadano il
giovane ha comunicato lo stesso a
prescindere e non è più soldi sulla
carta in questo caso cosa fai
mamma non è che l'abbia la festa si
possono effettuare i bonifici sulla
carta perché dovrei averlo anche su
avere un conto poi non so farmi abilito
sulla carta oppure possono scaricare
mela con l'app giusto di che però perché
mi lascia tempo la lega si è ragionato
vogliamo vedere se sei convinto pure
aree vuoi fare un regalo originale ad un
nipote di 15 anni dove non c'è cancellò
io 15 mar michael bruceranno punto
mediano che ce l'abbia puoi regalarti
una carta flash
sì perché a 15 anni sia perché andarci
lo saprete progetto presso il l ultima
domanda azzeccato tutto penale dell'aja
ripeto se non hai un conto come fai a
controllare alle spese che hai fatto
finora con la prima quella giusta quella
platea no basta che mi sono state
praticamente ti permette sono questo
spettacolo l'intesa per controllare sul
milione boom anche ma con questa rete è
un'app che serve a veronica e non altro
niente praticamente solo ai qua eccolo
qua visto giusto poi crescere anzi tre
ragazzi sono stati quando hai cambiato
nome
c'è un sacco di gente regala un attimo
non pensavo ci fosse così tanta gente
mancherà duri con la giacca con la
giacca brunella commenta cerca merini
secondo c'è il camerino con lavandino la
canzone ho mai visto e oggi che mi sono
messo questa camicia perché volevo fare
la persona elegante quindi l'ho portato
la giacca la camicia ho detto sono
sicuro ma sicuro
altre di labbra cento che mi macchie rho
sicuro perché io quando faccio i raduni
mi marchio sempre perché ci sono tutti
quei pennarelli affari famiglia
autografo nel farvi l'autografo e faccio
lotto averlo sempre no e quindi mi
impiastro tutte le mani su tutte sport e
quindi puntualmente sempre sempre sempre
mica del pennarello o qui ho qui o sul
pantalone da qualche parte mi cade oggi
ho messo lo smokey e la camicia che è un
caso rarissimo e ho detto vado a fare un
raduno con questi qui di sicuro mi
macchie rho sicuro ragazzi non mi sono
macchiato la prima volta che ho fatto
raduno e non mi sono macchiati
incredibile sono uscito dal raduno detto
non ci posso credere tolgo la giacca
limpido perfetto non mi sono macchiato
fantastico mi hanno messo le pizzette
quelle al sugo che ovviamente non ci
sono veri manager magnate prendo la
pizzi fate vita che stasera pizzetta al
sugo prendo la pizzetta faccio così la
mordo non parte mica fortissimo uno
schizzo di sugo rifinisce tipo 4 e non
lo vedete perché lo ha pulito era uscita
per un raduno senza sporcarmi porca
vacca niente vino sporcato con sugo
cos'è perché per che sputano i pacchi
legali veramente grazie dove avevi
chiesto un pallone in direi no ma il
pallone non è potuto arrivare però prima
del podio per di quello che c'è dentro
nostro male
vuoi dire così ma veramente no non ci
posso credere
l'autografo di paul john leica v day
ringraziare mehrin grazie proprio il
signor nba ma perché poi george oggi gli
auguri la fibra ed appoggio ma serio se
dio non ci fosse 5 grazie
[Musica]
di questo ragazzo è bravo anche oltre le
di emme musica vera ragazzo
[Musica]
siamo
a breve
i miei geni ma me lo mandi questo video
poco a mon ami tutto qui di oggi è stata
tanta paura
un bacino luogo al dito per chiedere un
po mi irritano che sto riprendendo io lo
so però che ci vediamo al prossimo blog
di pochissimo a parigi clough fiero
qualsiasi cosa
dimmi qualcosa in francese per
concludere la creatività bambini bablok
ma tu lo viene
solo quello che ha detto lui e ragazzi
bella ragazza bella ragazzi in francese
bella ragazza
per fendere facile fra quelle no no
[Musica]